hi adam and rich this is daniel pullman
from the mornington peninsula which is a
little over an hour outside of melbourne
australia um anyway my
question is my wife and i have been
long time vegetarians and we're
currently
slowly transitioning to a fully
plant-based diet
and we have two young children a
daughter who's
a little under three years old and a son
who's
about four months old and we're
grappling with
how and whether to raise them as fully
plant-based and particularly struggling
with
the societal pressures and peer pressure
that they're likely to sort of face
growing up based on the decision that
you know we're
sort of forcing it on them and i know
that i think your
whole family rich is vegan and
yeah just after some advice around your
thoughts around that
how you deal with it um what's the best
path you think
for us moving forward but yeah anyway
keep up the great
work from the other side of the world
guys peace out
uh thank you for your question daniel i
mean i think the the the best
course of action for you is what feels
right for you
you know it's not for me to tell you how
you should parent your children
i think you need to follow your own uh
intuition and instincts
about that but i think that
first of all say you can certainly raise
children
to be healthy on a plant-based diet and
the idea that you can't
has been thoroughly debunked so you
should feel confident that if that feels
right to you
that you are well supported in that
regard and that doesn't mean that
society has necessarily caught up with
that idea
and i understand and appreciate the
social pressures that
get packed into that and perhaps the
judgment that you might have to weather
but i would advise you against future
tripping like this idea well
if i do this then in the future at some
point they will be judged by their
classmates or their peers like that's
not the reality that you're living in
right now
what you're doing right now is just
trying to feed them the healthiest food
so that they can be
healthy the other notion
that i'd like to challenge you on is
this idea that you're
you're forcing it on them i mean you're
feeding your children
food are you forcing an ideology on them
are
is that any different from you're
forcing them to live in the house that
they live in or
to you know have any other ideas that
you feel strongly about
that's part of what parenting is you
know i don't think the word forcing is
the right word it's more like this is
the environment in which
we've decided to raise our
did you uh growing have raising the kids
did you have moments where
uh you know they strayed or they were
out of the house and had something or
like that that
time yeah and there's nothing wrong with
that yeah i mean our our approach with
our kids is we raise them plant-based
but you know when they became
old enough where they could make
decisions for themselves
we never policed those decisions like
our our idea was
we're going to have super healthy food
in the house we're going to cook
really delicious meals for the kids and
when they go over to their friend's
house we're not we
i'm not going to tell them you can't eat
this or that
we just try to educate them as best as
we possibly can
about what's in their best interest and
then the choices they make are up to
them
yeah and if they go to a friend's house
any cake or
pizza or whatever and come back
and they s and we say what did you eat
and they tell us i'm not going to judge
them either and make them feel bad about
that no
but we'll have a conversation like oh
how'd you feel after you ate that like
do you feel
you know a little bit of a stomach ache
or oh i liked it or whatever
i think when you the the the kind of
forcing
aspect of this comes into play when you
make them feel bad about themselves
because they've made a certain choice as
a young person
right um so we don't do that
and i think that has worked out pretty
well for us but each one of our kids has
had their own journey with all of this
and they've got to make their own
decisions for themselves so your job as
a parent is to provide the guideposts to
that and
educate them to the best of your ability
but also not get caught up in the small
things it's not about whether they ate
you know some candy or whatever it was
at their friend's house it's about what
their habits look like 10
15 20 years down the line like do they
have a healthy relationship with food
do they understand the foods that
nourish them versus the foods that
lead them towards chronic illness those
are the important factors and i feel
like that's what your responsibility is
as a parent
so no future tripping no guilt tripping
and um
but take a broad view and a long-term
view yeah yeah
yeah i think there's a little fear in
you know that i'm inferring in this
question
from maybe how their their sort of fan
friends and
well you know it's it's outside
melbourne so it's like
an hour outside a city so maybe in and
australia
it's not as there's plenty of
plant-based food in australia obviously
but
but it's not necessarily here in like
southern california to the same
level of acceptance so maybe some of
that is there mm-hmm i don't know
but like who's the great who's the
runner in louisiana
joshua joshua johnny he's like oh you
know he lives in
in the country in louisiana or whatever
and he's like
you know any grocery store in the world
you can do it so yes he knows well i
think also
when you you know as a new parent when
you have children that are
months old or you know just a couple
years old
like it's a very fragile situation
and you're so tuned in to like wanting
to make the right decision
for them and you feel that
responsibility right and you
the last thing you want to do is feed
them food that's going to harm them or
deprive them of food that's going to
harm them so i i'm
empathetic to you know what daniel is
you know considering right now he's like
oh if i don't feed them animals
everyone's telling me i should
these other people are saying it's
healthy but do i really know like do i
they you don't want to make a mistake
right so i get that yeah
i can promise you that you can raise
children healthy on a plant-based diet
there's lots of resources out there
um that i'm if you email me directly i'm
happy to share with you
but i think you should feel confident in
that regard
but if you're questioning that i think
that's normal as well and you've really
got to just trust your gut
[Music]
you